escalade de désarmement entre les deux
grands le président bush propose une
reddition immédiate de 89/100 des armes
chimiques ce week-end si moscou en fait
autant règlement de comptes à l'udf
françois leuthard battu par charles milo
à la tête du groupe parlementaire le
nouveau président en direct tout à
l'heure quel est le vrai niveau scolaire
des enfants premier test aujourd'hui
dans toutes les classes de 6e et de ce2
quatrième semaine de grève à sochaux et
à mulhouse la d1 qui développeront les
premières sanctions
monsieur bonsoir on dirait presque des
devoirs de vacances les cahiers sont
jaunes et bleus en 6e 11 et vert en ce2
de dans les tests mises au point par
l'éducation nationale pour évaluer dans
toutes les classes de france le
véritable niveau scolaire des enfants du
travail en plus pour eux mais aussi pour
les profs et pour les parents
shoretel kimmerlin jean-louis vous sers
moi c'est dans les étiquettes
ces cinq nouveaux nombre dès 8h30 la
maîtresse a distribué les cahiers de
tests du français et des mathématiques
exclusivement ronger leur douleur les
élèves n'avaient le droit qu au crayon à
papier et à la gomme une évaluation
réglé comme une horloge suisse anti
chaque exercice ne devait pas dépasser
trois minutes consignes ministérielles
oblige nous passons à l'exercice numéro
de padt exercice traditionnel non plus
du genre deux plus deux faucons bien ou
accorder telle verve aux participants ce
qui est testée aujourd'hui c'est la
proche qu'on les élèves de leurs
connaissances et le temps qu'ils mettent
à réfléchir en français pour le ce2 le
piège était de manger du bon pain et non
pas d'avaler des épines de pins même qu
il fallait savoir faire comparer ranger
placer les nombres plus que de résoudre
une simple addition ou une
multiplication
l'opération évaluation ne se termine pas
après les épreuves les enseignants de
cm2 et de 6e sont mobilisés pour toute
l'année à venir nous allons à partir de
ceux des résultats de l'évaluation
détecter les points faibles et essayé
d'initier les instituteurs et ils le
sont déjà en grande partie à une
pédagogie différenciée
c'est à dire une pédagogie qui prennent
en compte les difficultés de chacun des
élèves
alors ça peut être de soutien individuel
ça peut être aussi un travail par groupe
ou par atelier les parents d'élèves
seront informés du résultat des tests
dans les écoles au cours de la dernière
semaine d'octobre
oui la démarche ne fait pas tout à fait
l'unanimité syndicale force ouvrière et
la cgt sont contre expert l'a dit
beaucoup mieux mais victor en politique
qui doivent autant aux ambitions des
hommes qu'aux petites et aux grandes
trahisons
c'est ce que doit méditer ce soit
françois léotard que ses amis de l'udf
n'ont pas hissé à la présidence de leur
groupe parlementaire
le successeur de jean claude gaudin
s'appelle charles mines ont pourtant
rénovateurs en toile de fond plutôt en
ombres chinoises
valéry giscard d'estaing le récit de
l'empoignade à peine tempérée par l'eau
de vichy
véronique saint-élie jean-françois d'été
par qui charles millon at il été élu qui
a lâché françois léotard le patron du
parti républicain qui compte 55 députés
sur les 88 votants
aujourd'hui à vichy l'udf fait ses
comptes
léotard est reparti tout de suite à
paris sans amour jusqu à raboter puis il
est rentré à chamalières et sous la
tente chacun analyse à sa façon après
ces jeux de quilles
j'espère et qui seront finis et que
chacun se rassemblera pour faire
triompher notre message à libéral je
viens pour charles diplômés dame mais je
suis très malheureux pour
mon ami léotard parce que le groupe le
parti républicain l'opposition avait
besoin de lui charles millon c'est la
victoire aussi de valéry giscard
d'estaing
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr je crois
que vous leur présentez ça comme un
conflit par exemple vin rouge giscardien
comptant quelques uns c'est une erreur
je crois que c'est plutôt une victoire
ou ou une méconnaissance du milieu
parlementaire j'ai passé les victoires
de quelqu'un qui connaît bien milieux
parlementaires et qui a su bien se
présenter devant des députés
charles millon a donc réussi son pari il
apparaît au dessus des clans comme
l'homme de tous pourtant les giscardiens
se frotte les mains
les anciens barrister aussi philippe
mestre qui était candidat au premier
tour n'a pas hésité à soutenir millions
au second
et puis dans les coulisses on parle déjà
de règlement de comptes
jacques dominati et gérard longuet ont
le dialogue difficile moi j'ai millions
je vais demander des millions jal
permets moi te dire qu'avec des
décharges
on va d'abord selon lê van der sar et
ouais c'est très bien d'avoir un autre
père aussi avec gérard longuet madelin
quelques autres c'est très bien d'avoir
dans un action petit comme le nôtre à
l'idf décidément ces prêts et en est
simple mais une chose est sûre l'échec
de l'état ne restera pas sans suite
alors avec nous et avec gilles leclair
en direct de vichy charles millon
bonsoir et bravo
cette cette journée apparaît quand même
plutôt comme la défaite de léotard que
comme votre victoire avoue non non c'est
la victoire du groupe udf qui a pu avoir
un débat où on a entendu un certain
nombre de conceptions sur son avenir
durant toute la matinée il ya eu un
débat très sérieux entendu la conception
de françois léotard celle de films est
la mienne
et puis ensuite il ya eu un choix
démocratique oui enfin ça avait l'air
quand même beaucoup moins serein que ça
a c'est est très serein je souhaite à
huit clos c'était dommage mais c'était
très serein pour bien en sortant il y a
toujours des gens qui sont déçus parce
qu'ils ont leur champion et leurs
champions n'est pas retenue je suis bien
convaincu que françois le ter qui dans
la lettre qui nous avait adressé pour
nous présenter sa candidature que pense
le ter qui nous avait expliqué qu'en
aucun cas ça ne pourrait menacer
unité du groupe que c'était une élection
démocratique qu'on se déterminerait en
fonction des orientations de chacun que
françois leuthard qui a un grand talent
viendra nous aider maintenant à animer
le groupe parlementaire et continuera à
gérer le parti républicain charles
million votre tâche ne sera vraiment pas
très facile puisque dès cet après-midi
les amis de françois léotard se sont
réunis entre eux à l'hôtel de ville un
peu plus loin d'ici et menaces dès
maintenant de former une éventuelle
nouvelle structure dans un communiqué
que nous venons d'apprendre à l'instant
de quel type de structure si c'est une
structure d'influencé de travail je suis
même partisan de ce que je suis
pluraliste comme l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure christine ockrent je suis
rénovateurs je suis favorable à ce qu'il
y ait diversité des opinions dans un
grand mouvement
donc si mes amis du parti républicain
veulent s'organiser avoir des groupes de
travail faire valoir leurs convictions
non seulement je ne suis pas opposé mais
j'y suis favorable
sa maison est ce que vous avez remercié
valéry giscard d'estaing dont vous
demandiez pourtant le départ si je ne
m'abuse il ya trois mois je remerciais
toutes les personnes du groupe qui ont
participé à cette élection
le vote était secret je ne sais qui a
mis un bulletin millions ou un bulletin
léotard je sais simplement c'est que
maintenant je serai le président de tous
le groupe udf sans exclusion sans
exclusive charles millon gérard longuet
venait dire viens de dire à l'instant
qu'une majorité de circonstance a écarté
la personnalité la plus prometteuse de
l'opposition même en pensée c'est moi
j'admire les personnes qui lisent dans
le marc de café ou qui lisent dans les
urnes il ya une 45 personnes qui ont
voté pour moi je ne sais si c'est une
majorité de circonstance la seule chose
que je sais c'est que ce qu'une majorité
et c'est une majorité me donne des
devoirs
vous êtes tout de même une cible
formidable pour la gauche en ce moment
et peut-être même pour votre partenaire
du rpr on disait déjà l'udf malades
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas ce soir encore
plus malade mais la seule chose que je
peux vous promettre ce que à partir de
ce soir à partir de demain je ferai tout
pour que l'udf soit au centre de
position que l'udf retrouve sa culture
de position est que durant les débats
budgétaires qui vont s'ouvrir
durant les grands débats sur la loi de
programmation militaire nous fassions
valoir nous convient
on est que nous arrivions à démontrer
l'opinion publique que nous sommes
capables de constituer la force
d'alternance que nous appelons tous de
nos voeux la rénovation est en avant
pour la stratégie de l'union que
comprenait que défend par ailleurs
valéry giscard d'estaing
je suis toujours rénovateurs car je
crois qu'actuellement dans l'ensemble de
l'opposition il n'y a plus beaucoup de
personnes qui ne sont plus je suis
favorable à la constitution à terme
d'une grande force d'alternance
pluralité décentralisée est j'exposais
tout cela à mes collègues qui m'ont élu
ce matin 100 millions l'ayant je suis
bien sûr pour l'union parce que plus
personne est actuellement et pour la
division jeu on a toujours été pour
l'union et à la rénovation charme et
lyon est ce que c'est vraiment le
meilleur qui a gagné aujourd'hui je
l'espère salvio
merci au sein du parti socialiste maire
bilan au lendemain du triomphe de robert
rigaud aux sénatoriales gens peu
prennent le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement estime tout
simplement que la direction du ps des
bouches du rhône doit s'effacer dit il
après ce désaveu ambiance ambiance
marseille patrice brûlés comment tu
t'attends avec roger direct ligault
obligés de s'entendre quand je lui pose
une question il répond pas le cas je lui
écris je prends pas pas se discuter
robert vigouroux gère son succès en
force de tiers de silence un tiers
d'autoritarisme
tout passe par lui par ces décisions par
son image aussi l'image d'un homme
tranquille apolitique maire à plein
temps slogan de campagne municipale
écornée par sa candidature sénatoriales
le voilà bien sur le terrain politique
avec en ligne de mire la fédération
socialiste
une fédération amer de n'être pas resté
soudé face aux sirènes du succès comme
de certains membres nous qui tenons rang
parce que soi-disant la fédération n'est
pas démocrate et qu'ils vont se faire
désigner par que nous montons guillemets
qu'on appelle en monarque absolu
maintenant ses guérites la démocratie a
déjoué très variable en fonction de ces
données lésine pas sur des listes ou pas
alors le maire de marseille fait-il de
la politique sans le savoir
peut-être mais il s'en défend en jouant
sur les mots
je fais une politique depuis la
disparition de gaston defferre je
continue cette politique ce n'est pas
une question de goût c'est une question
de travail et quand vigouroux gagne la
fédération socialiste trinquent
ici plus personne ne sait comment
contrer ce drôle de dissidents quand le
désarmement change de front quand les
vents lui sont favorables mon secours
vient de relancer la négociation sur les
armes stratégiques
et voici que washington propose à son
tour une réduction immédiate et
drastique des armes chimiques
george bush l'a annoncé tout à l'heure
devant l'assemblée générale des nations
unies il suggère à moscou un plan de dix
ans mais sur ce front là les super grand
ne font pas nécessairement la loi larmes
chimiques restent aussi larmes du pauvre
vingtaine de pays on disposerait jacques
bouchard george bush n'est pas arrivé
les mains vides aux nations unies où il
avait représenté son pays en 1972
dans sa première intervention devant
l'assemblée générale en qualité de
président il a pris une initiative
audacieuse c'est le cas dans le domaine
des armes chimiques ios hydrique des
sports et nous sommes prêts à détruire
immédiatement 80 tours sens de notre
stock d'armes chimiques
si l'urss en fait autant alors que des
inspections mutuelle entre russes et
américains ont déjà eu lieu dans des
usines de production
george bush propose la conclusion d'un
accord dans un délai de huit ans après
la signature les états unis éliminerait
98 % de leurs armes chimiques
si moscou fait de même et 100 % au bout
de dix ans monsieur bush s'est déclaré
optimiste caste après les deux jours
d'entretiens en mains du ministre sous
vitrine marché vernal devrait arrêter
avec le secrétaire d'état james baker
dans le site enchanteur d'un parc
national au nord-ouest des etats-unis
les deux ministres ont signé une série
de protocoles qui
ouvre la voie à une interdiction totale
des stocks dans clean en fait après des
mois d'immobilisme un nouvel élan est
donnée aux relations entre moscou et
washington
à la tribune de l'assemblée générale
tout à l'heure le président bush a
d'ailleurs confirmé la tenue d'un sommet
avec mikhaïl gorbatchev au début de
l'été 90 et il a appelé la communauté
internationale à une coopération
prioritaires dans trois domaines la
sauvegarde de l'environnement et la
lutte contre la drogue et le terrorisme
qu'elle est l'explosif qui a détruit le
dc10 du terrain mardi dernier qui l'a
placé à bord et où l' enquête continue
difficilement et dans le désert les
recherches des corps des victimes ont
été suspendus aujourd'hui le point hervé
brusini les premiers débris du dc-10
sont arrivés ici la nuit dernière
aussitôt les spécialistes du laboratoire
central ont tenté d'identifier la nature
de l'explosif qui a provoqué la
catastrophe de l'avion du terrain les
enquêteurs y trouveront peut-être de
quoi les orienter vers les auteurs de
l'attentât
l'examen des gaz inhalés par les
victimes lui aussi peut être riche d'un
10 les autopsies sont pratiquées dans
cet institut médico légal
tous ces informations c'est à lui
qu'elle seront transmises le juge
bruguière pas simple pour lui
d'instruire une affaire à des milliers
de kilomètres du lieu des faits aussi
l'étudiant ce moment même la possibilité
de se rendre au niger
là bas les experts ont repéré des traces
de produits explosifs sur les parois
d'un conteneur un contenaire qui étaient
situées dans cette soute à l'avant de
l'appareil
on le voit les réservoirs étaient tout
proches à présent il va falloir dresser
l'inventaire des paquets chargé dans
cette partie du dc-10 et leur attribuer
leurs différents propriétaires
enfin il faudra établir le lieu précis
de l'embarquement de ses passagers de
leurs bagages à brazzaville où djamena
où se trouve la clé pour comprendre cet
attentat en afrique au proche orient
cette question essentielle c'est la dst
mandaté par le juge bruguière qui doit y
répondre
bien sûr les services de la dg se sont
aussi retravaille une douzaine de pistes
seraient actuellement explorées par les
enquêteurs qui évoquent pêle mêle la
syrie les filières chiite libanaise ou
encore la libye
et la famille de l'une des victimes le
metteur en scène jean pierre klein va
déposer une plainte contre x et se
porter partie civile afin d'être tenu au
courant des progrès de l'enquète le
conflit peugeot entre dans sa quatrième
semaine à sochaux et surtout à mulhouse
la production est toujours perturbée et
le climat tendu sur place maryse mano
vincent maillard rideau une centaine de
grévistes se prépare ta tâche et la nuit
dans la force de l usine de mulhouse
qu'il occupe depuis ce matin même
apparaître quelques merguez pour faire
passer appeltans quoi en attendant que
les compagnies
de l'équipe du mans à paris les postes
sont déserts la maîtrise et ceux qui
travaillent ont laissé le champ libre
aux grévistes
la paralysie de la seule force du groupe
peut gêner la production c'est une
question de temps le temps d'épuiser les
stocks de pièces cette action veut à la
fois remobiliser les salariés en
quatrième semaine de grève et riposter
aux premières lettres de licenciement
pour faute grave
reçu ce matin cet ouvrier turc est le
premier touché
il nie les faits qui lui sont reprochés
son licenciement dit il s'explique par
son refus de reprendre le travail
malgré les pressions du chef du
personnel m'a dit venez goûter au
travail et on vous paye la journée de
grève on vaut près le normand tation
mais ne sont pas des le vix alors je lui
avais dit désolé on n'achète pas quatre
autres lettres vont arriver ces jours ci
en même temps que les feuilles de paie
très légère pour les grévistes
henri krasucki ira jeudi à mulhouse
encourager les grévistes mais les
français dans leur majorité donne tort
au patron jacques calvet selon le
sondage que publiera demain le quotidien
de paris
76% des personnes interrogées sont pour
l'ouverture d'une négociation chez
peugeot parmi les arguments répétés par
jacques calvet vous l'avez entendu ici
même donc parmi ses arguments donc pour
justifier la rigueur de sa gestion
la pression de la concurrence étrangère
japonaise bien sûr mais aussi allemandes
il est donc intéressant de comparer la
situation chez peugeot à la politique
salariale menée par le groupe volkswagen
en allemagne fédérale
philippe rochot nous en donne les clés
c'est ouvrier de volkswagen travaille
comme auteur de la nouvelle passat ici
la dernière grève importante a eu lieu
en 84 3 millions de voitures seront
vendues cette année ce qui rapportera
2500 francs de plus à chaque ouvrier
salaires douze mille francs par mois
dans un pays où le coût de la vie est
seulement de 10% supérieur à celui de la
france
tél nous avons chaque jour des contacts
avec la direction
c'est que nous sommes presque une ville
trente sept mille personnes travaillent
ici
le dialogue est permanent quand il ya
des problèmes nous menacions d'arrêter
les heures supplémentaires mais en
général tout est réglé à statte 85 %
d'ouvriers syndiqués dans une industrie
automobile qui représente le sixième de
l'activité économique en allemagne
fédérale mais un seul syndicat par
branches industrielles avec obligations
en cas de conflit de nommer un médiateur
impartial
nous sommes bien payés
nous avons un système efficace
d'assurance sociale mieux que dans
d'autres secteurs de l'industrie
moi je travaille à l'atelier des chromes
et je suis heureux ici
tout fonctionne bien pour nous ici nous
avons un dialogue permanent avec la
direction
quand quelque chose ne va pas nous
discutons moi je suis électricien ici et
je n'ai pas de problème
au salon de l'auto de francfort quand on
parle du conflit peugeot les patrons de
l'automobile en allemagne répondent
toujours dialogue médiation mais aussi
motivation dans l'entreprise allemande
un système dit de la compréhension
réciproque
les ouvriers sont très motivés car nous
produisons de la qualité et nous les
intérêts sont à cela pour la nouvelle
passat nous avons créé des équipes
spéciales qui se sont passionnés pour ce
modèle et qui ont gardé le secret des
gens bien payés qui ont pu obtenir de
très bons résultats
volkswagen se vante d'avoir pu augmenter
ses ventes de 25% sur le marché français
en 90 elle sera capable d'offrir 3 %
d'augmentation à ses ouvriers pour 35
heures par semaine
ce soir encore tout le monde veut croire
à la paix à beyrouth
trois cent mille personnes sont même
revenus aujourd'hui dans les quartiers
qu'ils avaient fui pourtant le
cessez-le-feu a été violé ce matin par
des obus syrien sur la région chrétienne
louis carzou
mise en route de la phase politique du
plan arabe pour le règlement du conflit
libanais l'émissaire algeria monsieur
ibrahim sy a invité tous les députés
libanais à se réunir le 30 septembre en
arabie séoudite pour débattre d'un
document d'entente nationale
à l'exception de quelques tirs d'obus
syriens qui n'ont pas fait de victime
beyrouth a connu une journée de paix
relative symbolisée par la réouverture
de nombreux commerces
arrivé à paris de l'émir du koweït pour
une visite officielle de deux jours
cheikh jaber al sabah a été accueilli
par françois mitterrand avec lequel il
s'est entretenu dès cet après midi
au menu de ces entretiens les relations
économiques entre les deux pays
cependant précisé du côté koweïtien que
le contrat des mirage 2000 ne seraient
pas abordés
première apparition au public d'erich
honecker après un mois et demi d'absence
le chef de l'état reste allemand avait
dû subir une opération de la vésicule
biliaire en août dernier monsieur
honecker qui recevra dans quinze jours
mikhaïl gorbatchev doit maintenant
s'attaquer au problème des réfugiés est
allemand ainsi qu'à l'opposition
naissante à l'intérieur du pays
incendie à bord d'un ferry danois en mer
du nord bilan deux morts et dix blessés
légers
le temps scandinavia effectuer la
liaison entre la suède et la
grande-bretagne
lorsque le feu s'est déclaré dans une
salle où était entreposé du matériel de
l'ifri la police danoise a ouvert une
enquête sur l'origine du sinistre
+0 13% à la bourse de paris après une
séance d'hésitation les boursiers
craignent toujours une hausse des taux
d'intérêt quant au dollar il chute à 6
francs 45 35
les banques centrales des pays les plus
riches sont décidés à enrayer la hausse
de la devise américaine
le forage du tunnel sous la manche
devrait reprendre ce soir après une
semaine de grève la direction de
transmanche link a obtenu la levée du
piquet de grève qui bloque l usine de
sangatte dans le pas-de-calais
les syndicats réclament des garanties de
reclassement lorsque le tunnel sera
achevée il devrait être reçu demain par
la direction du chantier
les syndicats de police satisfait à
l'issue de leur rencontre avec le
ministre de l'intérieur le plan de
rénovation de la police et le budget
présenté par pierre joxe ont reçu un bon
accueil
quant aux revendications salariales des
policiers le ministre a promis une
réponse définitive le 15 octobre
prochain leur côté les syndicats des
gardiens de prison on relance le
mouvement de contestation à partir de
mercredi et à rennes les surveillants de
la maison d'arrêt sont entrés en grève
dès aujourd'hui si les boisserie
jean-françois chez le personnel
pénitentiaire fort mécontent du ministre
de la justice
le projet de budget du garde des sceaux
ne lui convient pas malgré une hausse de
7%
les syndicats réclament entre autres une
revalorisation des salaires
l'amélioration du régime de retraite et
des créations de postes quant à la
fermeture de 25 prisons déclaré vétuste
ils la jugent tout bonnement abusive et
comme tir arpaillange refuse selon eux
d'ouvrir sa porte
ils ont choisi de relancer un mouvement
de revendication dès le 27 septembre
arrêt des extractions judiciaires
suppression des parloirs et des visites
sauf pour les avocats dès mercredi les
prisons vont connaître leur troisième
paralysie depuis un an
kir arpaillange joue lui la fermeté les
syndicats ont fixé aujourd'hui les
limites de cette politique ministre
venait a préconisé des sanctions à
infliger des sanctions bien sûr ça
pourrait de se durcir dans les jours à
venir
les réactions le foie ont lutté brutale
ça si le personnel en provoque le
personnel
on peut s'attendre à tout cette nouvelle
brèche dans le paysage social français
s'annonce donc difficile à colmater
reddition du meurtrier du vigile des
galeries lafayette à marseille il s'est
constitué prisonnier dans un
commissariat de genève en suisse il
avait fui après le meurtre samedi
dernier la sécheresse de ces derniers
mois empoisonne l'eau potable c'est en
tout cas ce que l'on craint en
haute-vienne et aussi dans le
lot-et-garonne se fige ouvre dans le lot
et garonne
l'eau potable est sous haute
surveillance on craint qu'elle ne soit
plus irréprochable au banc des accusés
la sécheresse ici dans les eaux
particulièrement basses de la garonne
les rejets polluants des entreprises ne
sont plus assez diluer les ags fortes
consommatrices d'oxygène se développe
alors cette eau est elle responsable des
cas de typhoïde et de gastro entérite
recensés ces derniers jours pour
l'instant de fortes présomptions mais
aucune certitude
chaque jour des prélèvements sont faits
pour analyse et déjà dans les usines de
traitement d'eau les dose de chlore ont
été augmentées pour assurer une
meilleure ses réalisations
ce soir le préfet du lot-et-garonne sun
alarme et menacent de fermer les
entreprises les plus polluantes du
département
et dans le gers on craint une flambée de
salmonellose cinq personnes d'une même
famille empoisonné par la même boulette
sont hospitalisés à auch important de
fils de gaz naturel à chémery dans le
loir et cher sur un site de stockage
souterrain de gaz de france est le plus
important d'europe
pas de danger pour l'environnement
affirme ce soir la direction
les entretiens de bichat or qui tous les
ans réunissent à paris plusieurs
dizaines de médecins sociaux de
recyclage les entretiens de bichat ont
commencé aujourd'hui
plusieurs communications intéressants
dont une qui concerne tout le monde à un
moment ou un autre et surtout les femmes
il s'agit de la fatigue sauver cette
fatigue qui vous prend au 1 ou à l'âme
les médecins à l'appel l'asthénie et
c'est aujourd'hui pour les généralistes
le premier motif de consultation à
prendre donc au sérieux vincent erhart
daniel lévy vous trouvez que vous êtes
souvent fatigué
souvent oui trop souvent le bruit je
fais un bureau paysager et le menu
fatigue les enfants ça engendre beaucoup
beaucoup de choses de la fatigue entre
autres exemples comment ça se manifeste
a pâti chez vous les jambes
les gens nous rv messieurs à chaud des
sueurs froides
c'est surtout la tête maux de tête vous
allez voir votre médecin cause de la
fête supermicro régulièrement tous les
mois
qu'est ce que vous avez comme remède
varia d'erika mann center polyvalent
tape derrière ces chats tilly a souvent
une diminution des capacités de
l'individu et il faudra que le médecin
généraliste découvre l'année me l'ulcère
l'infection la tente ou tel ou tel autre
agression et c'est notre travail que
d'aller le rechercher
et puis un certain nombre de causes ne
correspondent pas à ceux assez voit bien
classique et somatiques et ce sont
simplement les inadaptations alors on
parle le surmenage ou de stress on parle
de l'inadaptation en gros c'est ça le
problème
le sujet ne ressent plus vis-à-vis de
l'effort fourni
la gratification qu'il en attend il est
un peu perdu il n'éprouve pas il n'est
pas bien dans sa peau
c'est très souvent mal exprimé la
fatigue c'est souvent un malaise c'est
cette sensation mal dit mal fait on a
mal on n'est pas bien c'est bien de
n'être mais s'est péniblement sentais la
fatigue un symptôme que le généraliste
doit absolument traiter car il peut
cacher des situations graves
attention dopants qui ne peuvent que
faire illusion quelques temps la
solution passe surtout par un changement
de vie un problème individuel mais aussi
de sociétés
oui c'est un problème qui n'affecte pas
que les gens des villes soulignent les
spécialistes eux sous marin à paris il
s'appelle l'argonaute il est à la
retraite et il est arrivé à la villette
au terme d'un voyage bien compliqué
qu'on saisit patrick esther et passent
quelques lignes elle en a pourtant vu
les cluses de la briche sur le canal
saint-denis les mêmes pendant la guerre
un sous-marin jamais et bien c'est fait
ce matin l'argonaute franchissait les
dernières encablures le séparant de la
ville
lancé en 1957 ce sous-marin de 400
tonnes aura servi 24 ans dans la marine
française
mais lorsqu'il est désarmé en 82 à
toulon il est usé rouillé quarante mille
heures de travail de rénovation et la
direction générale de l'armement décidé
d'en faire don à la cité des sciences et
de l'industrie
nous l'avons entièrement transformé nous
avons percé des portes sur le côté pour
permettre l'accès au public et bien sûr
qu'est ce que le public va pouvoir foire
ou essayez d'abord il pourra voir
essentiellement les cuisines et surtout
essayer le périscope bien sûr attraction
numéro une étude us moral
le bâtiment restaurer se trouvait en
rade de toulon
ce dernier voyage vers paris a
probablement été le plus original
d'abord placé sur l'immense barrage
entre toulon et le havre
il fallut ensuite le remettre à l'eau
pour finalement le soulever grâce à des
boudins gonflables
afin de respecter le tirant d'eau de la
scène et des canaux le kiosque découpé
pour passer sous les ponts sera bien sûr
ressouder pour l'exposition allez me
reste à vous donner les pronostics de
pierre de bresse pour le quinté plus et
le tiercé de demain à vincennes 18
partants ses favoris le neuf le 6 le 11
le 15 le dise le 14 le 3 et le 16
alors c'est tout se fit d'avant dans un
instant après la pub et puis vers minuit
henri sannier vous donnera les dernières
informations de la journée très bonne
soirée à demain la terre
à